32 1486 mort très exactement
c'est le dernier bilan officiel du coc
vite 19 en italie
des chiffres alarmants mais pourtant
sous-évalué selon la sécurité sociale
italienne
selon elle dix neuf mille décès
supplémentaires seraient à déplorer dans
le pays soit plus de 50 mille morts au
total duo coronavirus ce qui ferait de
l'italie le pays le plus touché par la
pandémie en europe et le deuxième dans
le monde derrière les etats unis
selon l'étude le nord du pays affiche
une hausse de la mortalité de 84% par
rapport aux précédentes années alors que
le centre et le sud affiche 11 et 5 %
des données suffisantes pour contredire
les chiffres du gouvernement
la quantification des décès par kobe 19
réalisé à partir du nombre de patients
décédés est positif fournit
quotidiennement par le département de la
protection civile est à présent
considérés comme peu fiables
outre cette bataille des chiffres rome
doit aussi faire face à la colère des
médecins et infirmiers du nord qui sont
montés au créneau pour dénoncer la
baisse des rémunérations par les
collectivités locales
une baisse consécutive à un dépassement
du budget de plus de 6%
lequel était inévitable avec la crise
ducobu de 19,6 l'exécutif de la
lombardie n'a pas encore réagi plusieurs
associations d'aides-soignants n'entend
pas en rester là
et oui si nous dépassons les budgets la
région déclare qu'elle ne paiera ses
services que partiellement à mon sens
c'est injuste car les besoins de la
population augmente avec le
vieillissement de la population ou des
badges
cela fait des années que les budgets
n'ont pas bougé chaque année nous
ignorons s'il y aura de l'argent pour
couvrir les services que nous avons déjà
assurée ce n'est pas normal de se
demander chaque fin d'année
si ces services vont être remboursés
aussi c'est nous les organisations de
santé qui devront les couvrir de notre
poche lausanne
alors que la crise sanitaire n'est pas
terminée l'italie doit déjà se préparer
à d'autres batailles sociales et
économiques avec pour nouvelle priorité
le secteur de la santé lui aussi en
réanimation